how many species are there how many
species are there on this planet where
an individual specimen can change its
gender that happens in nature
human beings are not designed to do that
that's fine everybody can't change their
nature through their mind yeah yeah in
my opinion you know the whole point of
hearing people a human woman becoming
pregnant by herself now this is a very
rare occurrence okay but the thing with
genetics is things are weird and we we
do there is a woman that got pregnant by
herself were you guys following her
making sure that she didn't go and
inseminate her so that's this is the
thing like this story scientific
weirdness is a thing that happens